>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Kerri Willette: My
name is Kerri Willette.
I'm here with folks from the
Empire State Digital Network.
And I'm just going to give
you a real quick overview
of the service hub, and then
I'm going to let the folks
on the ground do some talking
about what the work
actually involves day to day.
I'm going to start by
making some introductions.
First, brief 101 about
New York State,
which is its own delightful
entity of, you know,
wonder, and did I say delight?
I think I did.
[Laughter] Okay, good.
So since the 1960s, the state
of New York has been divided
up into these sort of nine regions
for the purposes of legislating
and distributing funding,
and all of that stuff.
It kind of breaks up
on county lines.
But there are nine regions.
All of the libraries and archives
in the state or, you know,
the majority of libraries and
archives in the state make
up this Empire State Library Network
or participate in it, I would say.
And the Empire State Library
Network is nine regional councils.
So each region in the state
has a council that serves.
It's a multi-type library council
that serves libraries and archives
in their region, in their
geographic region of the state.
So each has its own lovely acronym.
I memorized them all.
And we also have in
the state preexisting
in the service hub three
large-scaled digital --
collaborative digital
collection projects.
So regions offer -- the councils
in each region offers a suite
of services to their membership.
So it's like, everything
from interlibrary loan
and sometimes chat reference
support, to digital services,
so hosting digital
collections, content
and doing digitization trainings
and services for their members.
So each council does
that in their own way.
But that's what's happening
throughout the state.
Seven of those councils collaborate
on one shared big digital collection
project called "New York Heritage",
which you'll hear more about.
And then two of the councils host
their own digital collections
locally in support
of their membership.
So we have Hudson River Valley
Heritage at Southeastern New York.
And in New York City at Metro,
we've got Metro's Digital Culture.
So those are sort of the
big large-scaled projects.
And then, of course, throughout
the state in every region,
there are institutions that also
host their own content locally.
So, for example, in Rochester we
have the University of Rochester
who hosts their own stuff instead of
participating in New York Heritage,
or one of the shared
collaborative projects.
So those are our partners statewide.
And then oh yes, this one.
I'm going to introduce us.
Again, my name is Kerri Willette.
I manage the service
hub out of the council
in New York City, which
is called "METRO".
And in DC that makes me
sound like I drive a train.
[Laughter] I don't, but I'd like to.
And then Laura Osterhout is going
to talk to us from the perspective
of Rochester Regional Council --
I guess I didn't memorize
what they stand for,
Rochester Regional Library
Council, and she's going
to give us some background on
the state sort of collaborations
that have happened over time.
Susan D'Entremont is
here from Albany
in the capital District
Library Council.
Jennifer Palmentiero is here
from Southeastern New York
Library Resources Council.
And she manages Hudson
River Valley Heritage,
which is one of those collaborative
projects I was talking about.
So we're going to hear
from each of them.
The hub itself, Empire State Digital
Network, we have a staff of three.
We live at the METRO offices.
METRO hosts and administers
basically the technology of the hub
and project management
workflow and things like that
for coordinating aggregation.
ESDN is a straight-up aggregator.
We are not a repository.
We do not have a frontend
portal at this time,
although we'd like to build
one, and we're working on it.
And then, you know, it's
really coming from the councils
where all our content is, right?
So all of the council members
go to their one person on staff
in each region if they want to
participate in contributing to DPLA.
So in, you know, Albany if there's
a library that wants to contribute
to DPLA, Susan is the face of DPLA
in New York for that person, right?
And that's true of
each regional council.
So together we've done pretty
well over the last two years.
We have over 181 institutions
contributing
to DPLA through our network.
And we're up over 200,000 objects,
and going strong, we're growing.
And now I'm going to let the
folks who are actually are
on the ground doing all the
stuff come and talk to you
about that; so starting with Laura.
[ Silence ]
>> Laura Osterhout: Thank you.
Hey, everybody.
It's good to see so
many people here today.
Can you hear me okay?
I hate the sound of my own voice.
[Laughter] So I am going to tell
you a bit about the building blocks
that we had in place in
New York that enabled us
to connect everything up and
make a really successful hub.
And as Kerri mentioned already
to you, there are the three sort
of main digital content
sites in New York.
I'm going to talk about how
we sort of started with these
and connected everything to be
the foundational pieces of the hub
and contribute to the success.
So Kerri went through the nine
library councils that we have.
We make up the Empire
State Library Network.
And we collaborate very heavily now,
but that wasn't always the case.
And so up until about ten years
ago, we didn't work as closely
with each other as we do now.
And in 2006 to 2009 timeframe,
there was a real push for us
to work closely together, reduce
redundancies, and things like that.
I joined the councils in 2007.
So I came in right
at that time period.
And so just to give you a bit of
background of the digital landscape
of New York at that time,
each of the nine regions had
their own regional digital
heritage collection.
And they all happened
to use CONTENTdm.
So there were nine different
licenses of CONTENTdm
around the state, not counting some
of our other partners
who had their own.
And so as we were talking and
looking for ways to collaborate,
we're thinking, "Does
it really make sense
to have nine separate
regional sites?
Could we save money?
Could we streamline?
And then what about the
experience for our end users?"
In my region in Rochester,
the regional site was called
"Finger Lakes and Genesee
River Valley Heritage".
It didn't mean a ton to
the people in my region,
and it meant even less
outside of there.
So trying to pull together some sort
of statewide option
made a lot more sense.
So we talked about that, and we
were in conversations with all
of the library councils about that.
And we ended up beginning
a merge in about 2010.
And we were lucky because
we were all in CONTENTdm,
so that helped a lot, actually.
And we started with
an unlimited license
from the Western New
York Council WNY Alert,
which is in the Buffalo region.
So we used that to --
as the base to pull
in content from the other sites.
And each merge was
a little different,
just because everybody's
local situation was different.
Some people were hosted at OCLC.
Some people hosted their own.
But, you know, we made it
work, and it was easier
because we were on
the same platform.
And then we brought the first
sort of the up-staters everything
above the [inaudible], we
brought in by the middle of 2011.
And then our most recent addition
is the Long Island Council.
And we -- I think we officially
added everything from them
at the end of 2005, I believe.
So we're really representing
a huge part of New York.
It's been really successful.
The other two major building blocks
that we were pulling
together are the HRVH,
that's Jen's area,
Hudson River Valley.
And I'm just going to
call it "Digital Metro",
because that's what
I remember it as.
[Laughs] And I want
to talk a little bit
about why these two sites are
separate from New York Heritage,
and there's really good reasons for
that, and why it's totally fine.
And I also want to give a shout-out
to Jen and HRVH and their region.
They were -- I think all of us
from New York can agree they
were really some of the pioneers
in collaborative, large-scale
digital projects.
And when we were forming all of
our New York Heritage standards,
especially Metadata, we basically
cribbed everything from them.
So I just want to give
you a shout-out
because it was a huge help.
She's going to talk
about Metadata later.
But both of these two
projects, in particular,
really want to maintain local
control of their front and back end,
and their ability to make changes.
And New York Heritage
has hosted OCLC,
so we are more limited
in what we can do.
And that's okay, and
it works for us.
But for these two particular
projects,
their users really expect
that level of control.
And so that really
makes sense for them.
In addition, they both
had, you know,
really good brand recognition
among your members.
And it didn't necessarily
make sense to abandon that.
And at the time of the merge, we
had a CONTENTdm multisite server,
which is, you know, like a glorified
federated search, essentially.
So we were able to target
whatever CONTENTdm site collections
that we wanted to.
But OCLC stopped supporting that
a couple of years ago, I think.
So, you know, up until
that point, it was fine.
There was a way to
connect everything,
but then there was this gap.
And then along comes DPLA.
[Laughs] So it's really a
lot less important that we're
in different sites and different
systems even because, you know,
the team at ESDN is looking at
using the DPLA API to create sort
of a New York State portal
search, which is wonderful.
It solves the problem for us that
we've been working on, you know,
for ten years and we
didn't have a solution for.
So it's just been amazing.
Let's see.
How am I doing on time?
I've been practicing and
I couldn't get it down.
Oh, good, all right.
So the other ways that these
foundational building blocks
contribute to the success of
the hub is that you could see
from the other -- I mean, the map,
like everything is represented
within these projects.
So pulling the data
from these projects in,
in sort of the initial wave
[inaudible] just covered the
whole state.
So it was really --
not low-hanging crew,
and I know it wasn't super easy,
but it was a great way
to just blast it out.
And it enabled us to get a
statewide hub going faster.
And these projects we really -- we
worked directly with our membership,
our libraries on high-quality
metadata.
[Laughs] And I always look at Jen.
She's my metadata girl.
And it -- we've been working
on it for a long time.
And we are able to sort of make the
global tweaks that are necessary
to make the data understandable
when you view it from the DPLA lens.
And it's really helpful to us,
because we didn't necessarily --
you don't always think about,
"What does your stuff look like out
of the context of the
system that it's in?"
So that's been really helpful.
I think that's all I wanted
to say about that one.
Okay.
[ Silence ]
And as Kerri mentioned to you, the
regional liaisons are the main face
of DPLA, at least at first
when someone is interested
in participating.
And that benefits all of us,
really, because we get more --
understand the institutions and the
libraries in our regions very well.
And we have great relationships
with them.
And so it's easier for us to
contact them, to talk to them,
to know their particular situation.
And it does help, I think, ESDN
because there's no way the staff
of three could talk to all
the different libraries
and members that we do.
So that's mutually beneficial.
And we also -- in having
these conversations,
we are able to see different
collaborations that we might have.
So, for example, if
there was an institution,
say like a historical society in my
region, maybe they want to be a part
of DPLA, but they're not
a member of our group yet.
So I can talk to them.
I can say, "Hey, these are
the services that we provide.
These are the projects we have going
on that you could participate in
and ultimately get, you
know, funneled into DPLA."
So it's like a win-win.
You know, we get new collections,
DPLA gets new collections.
It's just all good; good all around.
Okay. So I was going to put
a cat on this, but I didn't.
[Laughter] I was trying to
make some building blocks,
and this is what happened,
so I apologize about that.
So before I turn this over to
Susan, I just wanted to say
to anybody that's in the
audience that is thinking
about forming a statewide hub, you
know, we were lucky in New York
because we had a really
strong background
of networks going already,
but what I would say to you is
to just take a look
around your state
and identify the large-scaled
projects that you have,
identify the partnerships, even
the networks that you have,
even informal things, because
you may look around and find
that you have a lot of the building
blocks already that are necessary
to connect up and make
a successful hub.
And so I will turn it over to
Susan who will tell you what it's
like to actually work
with the members.
[ Applause ]
>> Susan D'Entremont: Well, I
had my remarks all prepared.
And then I had dinner last
night with these ladies,
and I got a lot more ideas.
So I think Kerri's probably
going to have to cut me off.
But Laura provided a great overview
of our process throughout the state.
And I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about the point of view
from our ten county region around
Albany, which consists of urban,
suburban, and rural members.
I'm not going to talk too much
about our specific way that we train
to do things, because we all
do it a little bit differently.
But I'm sure we'll all be happy to
answer questions at the Q&A time.
But I will say, for some of
you who are from bigger states,
we actually train most
of our people remotely,
because our trainer moved
to Atlanta, Georgia.
And we did it out of necessity, but
it's worked really, really well.
So we can talk about that.
Okay. Sometimes size doesn't matter.
We went into this thinking, "Oh, we
have these great big institutions.
We have the University of Albany,
we have Skidmore, so forth.
They're going to be
so eager to join DPLA
and the little people are
going to be a lot of trouble.
[Laughter] Or they're going to --
we're going to have
to coax them along."
And we thought that that's
not necessarily true at all,
that basically the
smaller places a lot
of times have a lot
more flexibility,
they can turn their
ship more quickly,
and that the bigger
institutions have --
they really invested in
doing things their own way,
and to try to get do things our way
or the DPLA way takes
a lot more work.
So really the small people were
-- are fairly easy to bring in.
And we're also finding that
they have a lot more skills
than maybe we thought
that they would.
We happen to have a lot of
-- I mean, the capitals,
we happen to have a lot of state
worker retirees who do IT work.
So we're lucky that way.
But that it's more of the getting
people to buy into the idea has been
as much of an effort as
teaching them the skills.
[ Silence ]
First of all, most of these
are probably pretty obvious
to people in the room.
But having -- all the supervisors
can be like, "Yes, yes, join DPLA,"
but they weren't -- they're
not necessarily willing to turn
over the labor resources
needed to do that.
So we started -- and we were really
surprised, too, that even people
in museums and libraries, they --
a lot of the people in charge
weren't really very different
from the general public in
thinking like, "Yes; put it online.
It's really easy."
So we started to do a very
brief application process,
which wasn't so much of a
weeding or vetting process,
but more like answering,
"Who's going to do scanning?
How are you going to --
who's going to do metadata?
How are you going to do it,"
to kind of get them to think
about what's involved, and yes
to decide that they do want
to take the effort to go into this.
And then the supervisor
has to sign off on that
so they know what they're doing.
And one person willing to own it
who could very well be a volunteer,
but one person who's
really, really into it.
And that's been one of our big
challenges is those people change,
those people leave, and you have
this really vibrant collection
that then just stops.
And we try not to take it
personally, but sometimes we do.
The third bullet, detail-oriented,
yet not too bogged down in details,
people that are like
that, that's a sweet spot
that I think is the most
difficult thing for us to meet.
We have institutions that
follow that, you know,
they'll put up an item,
and a title, and that's it.
And then we have other
institutions who want
to research every single thing.
And I think working with
Empire State Digital Network,
which I'll talk about in a minute,
has really helped us fine-tune that
and get people to have
their ducks in a row.
And flexible, good humor
and then patience basically
when you're starting a hub,
I would highly recommend
that you pinpoint members
that you know --
early participants who you know
are willing to go with the flow,
and are willing to change things,
because you are going to have
to make them change
everything they've done,
or change their workflow
for your very first members.
And then now we're at the point
where I think we have a
workflow pretty well set up.
And newer members it's much
easier for them to join.
And willing to give up some control.
We all have trouble
with that, don't we?
We found that the smaller places
are very worried about their stuff,
like they're afraid --
and you've all heard this,
they're afraid they're
going to lose money
and we keep showing them the
stats like, "No; actually,
people know you exist,
and they'll find you,
and they'll visit you,
and they'll buy things."
And they're also worried
about people doing bad
stuff with their images.
Like I had one historical
society someone said, "Well,
what if they take our image and
they like put a word balloon over it
that says something really bad?"
"I don't know.
You just have to give that up
if you're going to be in DPLA."
The bigger places we're more worried
about losing professional control,
we've had some of the bigger
institutions going into DPLA,
like not even New York institutions,
but institutions in other parts
and saying, "Well, what
are they doing here," and,
"Why do they have this
metadata in there,"
and "Why aren't they
doing it our way?"
And so, you know, just -- you have
to talk them through it and say,
"Well, if you're going to be
in DPLA, there's going to be --
you're going to have to
follow our rules a little bit,
and there's also going
to be people in there
that are doing things
not exactly the way
that you do them, and that's okay."
And then Laura did a really good job
at explaining our different regions.
And we have all had to give up
a little bit of our control.
We all do things slightly
differently.
Our memberships' needs are
different in each region.
And that's been hard too, but
we have to be okay with the fact
that everyone does things
a little bit differently.
Well, everyone, if
you're talking about DPLA,
you want to have some
things from DPLA in there.
So these are a couple of examples
of institutions in my region.
The first, the Dunadins
with their cycle
at Luna Park, Rexford, New York.
This is from the Clifton
Park-Halfmoon Public Library,
which is a suburb basically
halfway between Albany and Saratoga.
So people -- so it's for
couples who have people that work
in both places live there.
And it's a very, very
popular collection.
It was only a few hundred items
in there, and there will be
like 50,000 hits in a month.
And it's -- you know,
I think everyone thinks this
is a really boring suburb
with nothing to do.
And, you know, yet
it has this history,
and it's gotten a lot of hits.
They had a historian and a
librarian working together,
which has been a very good
partnership for many of our members,
where the historian has the
content in the metadata,
and the librarian actually puts it
in and does the collaborative stuff.
But then the librarian took
a job at another library,
and so that's been a
dormant collection.
And again, we have
to be okay with that.
This is the Rudolf Steiner Library
of the Anthroposophical Society
in America, which is a tiny, tiny
library with a halftime librarian.
It has moved twice since they
joined New York Heritage,
but they have a real -- but they've
put in a lot of wonderful stuff.
They have a great librarian that's
like the Waldorf School
Biodynamic Farming Movement.
They have a real mission.
And they've put a lot of stuff in.
People want to be told, but
they don't always listen.
People -- we gave them
guidelines, two pages of guidelines.
People didn't like that.
Now we have 60-page guidelines.
They love that.
[Laughter] But they don't
always do what we say.
So Empire State Digital
Network has helped us
to get the people to listen.
Kerri and Chris Stanton, who's the
metadata guy, they are experts,
but they're also perceived
as experts.
They can tell our members things.
We could tell them the same thing,
and that's just that crazy librarian
in Albany, but -- oh, two minutes.
But when we say that
Empire State Digital Network
and DPLA says you need to do
this, then they'll listen.
Also now that they know that
their things are national,
they don't want to be embarrassed.
So they'll, you know, make sure
their things are right-side
up and that sort of thing.
They have had renewed enthusiasm,
like lots of people were waning.
And now that we've joined DPLA,
they're putting more things in.
And then it's been very,
very helpful, I think,
to give them the resources, the
labor, and the money resources
from their boards and
from the administrators,
because they were doing
a great job before.
But now saying they're part
of DPLA, they'll do that.
And Empire Digital State Network has
been able to provide us with tools.
This is a tool.
Jen's going to talk in a
minute more about metadata,
but this is something
that Chris Stanton
of Empire State Digital
Network created
to help us with our metadata.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Oh, okay, so from North
Carolina; I didn't know that.
And we also helped the hub.
We provide --
[ Silence ]
People for their committees.
Our staffs and our library staffs
were able to pinpoint people
because we know them well,
people from the region
for their working group.
We get them out of their
ivory tower down in New York
and tell them what
it's like in the field.
We are able -- we have
permission letters --
rather than a memorandum
of understanding we have just
very brief permission letters
that Kerri developed,
and that's been helpful.
And --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes, oh, they sell it
from North Carolina.
I didn't know.
We were just copying North Carolina.
And people, you know,
they're nervous
about signing these legal documents.
I'm nervous about signing it, and I
think when we have that, you know,
that more one-on-one
relationship we'll be able
to get that permission up.
And I'm very excited about hearing
about that rightstatements.org.
So we're going to be able to help
ESDN get good rights [inaudible]
to get a lot of metadata taking
up a lot of room out of there.
And in turn they're going
to be able to help us.
I had a lot of problems with
people thinking they have copyright
that they don't have.
And so I think this discussion --
besides pointing them to this book,
this discussion that we need
for DPLA will help with that.
[ Silence ]
Well, what are participants
going to do?
Right now we're very, very --
just like DPLA, we're a new hub.
What is it, how long, a year?
Okay.
>> Two years.
>> Susan D'Entremont: Two years.
Does our members still --
we still -- we don't --
most of us don't charge
our members at this point.
We will have to at some point.
So I think they're going to look
at the value versus the cost.
Is it worth what they perceive
as red tape to be in DPLA?
I hope they say yes.
And looking -- we haven't had a
chance yet to look at our stats
to see how much DPLA has
helped them get views.
So that's for the future.
And now onto Jen.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
Hello, everybody.
And we don't use the
word "stealing",
we use "creatively repurpose."
[Laughter] That's what we do
with each other's stuff, so.
Okay; so come on a journey with me
into the weeds of metadata
harvesting.
And everything Susan said is true
for our Hudson River
Valley Heritage Environment,
in terms of who our members and
how all of that kind of plays out.
So what she said.
Okay; so I'm going to
talk about my workflow
with my Hudson River
Valley Heritage members,
and how I get their
metadata ready for DPLA.
And I have about 30 seconds to
share with you on what ESDN does
with the non-hosted
repositories in our state.
So you can get a little
understanding
of what that looks like.
So I do an assessment.
When I get a collection ready after
they've signed a permission letter,
I take a look at the collection,
see what I'm dealing with.
And then there's some consultation
that happens, sometimes with Chris
at ESDN if I have some questions
before I go to my member.
And then I will talk to my member
about some things that
need to change.
And I do about 90% of the
cleanup for them, but I am lucky
that my collections
are all really small.
Most of them are under
1,000 objects.
We have a few in the few thousand.
Our largest is 5,500.
That one didn't get as cleaned up
as often as some of the others.
So then I do the cleanup.
And then I map our fields according
to a spreadsheet that
Chris provides me.
And then they do the transformation.
So before I kind of go into
collection level workflows,
I want to talk about assessment
for just another second, or two,
or five, that we had to kind of look
at our higher-level
metadata guidelines,
and see what needed
to be changed there.
We had to change some
of our mapping.
We're all CONTENTdm shops.
CONTENTdm is very flexible in
terms of your field labels,
what you present to the user.
We can map those to
[inaudible] fields or not.
So we did have to change
some of our mapping
to make our resources more
shareable, and un-map some things.
I thought we were going
to have to like,
maybe really do some things
differently in a couple of fields.
And it turns out that so
far, that hasn't happened.
You can be a little different,
as long as you're consistently
different,
then ESDN can work with it.
I still might revisit a couple
things, and that might be phase two
of metadata cleanup, really kind
of making some things a bit
more shareable and less messy.
Okay. So again we're
a CONTENTdm shop.
So the first thing I do is I export
all of the records into Excel
so I can filter on field
to see where I'm kind
of -- where some problems are.
Also in CONTENTdm, we have the
ability to kind of browse list
where we have controlled
vocabularies enabled so I can kind
of see when a person's going
to index five different ways;
and take a look at that.
And all of our metadata cleanup
has to happen in CONTENTdm.
Unfortunately, we can
get the data out,
we could even wrangle it all we
want in something like OpenRefine
or Excel, but we can't
stick it back in.
So this is part of the reason
why I do a lot of the cleanup
for our members is because I've
been using CONTENTdm for 12 years.
I know how to maximize the software
to get it done quickly
and efficiently, so.
[ Silence ]
So I look at every field.
I'm going to highlight a few here.
But I do take a look at everything.
Some fields are easier to clean
up, some are pretty normalized.
You know our internet media
types and our language codes,
those tend to be pretty
standard, and if they're not,
that's kind of an easy fix.
Some are more complicated.
I have subjects [inaudible]
formats in italics here,
because this is an older
version of the PowerPoint,
and that I wasn't sure
I was going talk
about those, but I am apparently.
So we'll see what we've
got going on here.
All right.
So let's just kind of get into this.
So in an ideal world,
we know when all
of our resources were
created; that never happens.
And we do try to adhere to
the international standard.
It's in our guidelines.
And interestingly enough,
12 years ago
when we developed our guidelines, we
tried to normalize on certain days
with just a question mark.
We thought it would
be easy to script out,
or to otherwise remove
from indexing.
And it turns out people really
don't like that question mark.
It means something
different than circa.
They're really, really tied to that
word "circa" or the letters C A,
or the letter C, or all
three in one collection.
So -- [laughter] it happens.
And so I have to do some
kind of wrangling about that.
And we were allowing them to keep
the circa, and just do it one way
to make it easier for ESDN
to write a script to indicate
that that's an uncertainty.
Here are more date formats.
Some of this is just they
don't read the guidelines.
[Laughter] So I clean all this up.
And we've kind of gone to date
ranges for like the top three,
and deal with some of these
other formats in other ways.
And the bottom two
are just wrong, so.
Okay, again, geographic
locations; and this is one area
where I thought we
were going to have
to really do things
differently, because nobody else
in the whole entire country does it
this way, except New York Heritage
because they creatively
repurposed our guidelines.
[Laughs] So and, you know, we --
there were decisions
behind all this.
We sat and talked about geographic
formats for like a whole day.
And this is what we came up with.
So we ask our members to do it
this way, and in reality we get all
of these different formats.
Some is just punctuation, and
then some is they didn't read
the guidelines.
So I normalize all those.
And maybe we'll go
back and we'll revisit,
but right now this
hasn't been a problem.
Again, we're different, but we're
consistently different, so okay.
Personal names, very
hyperlocal collections.
You're not going to find
the majority of your people
in the Library of Congress
name authority file,
or any other authority file.
We have some.
We deal with famous artists
and revolutionary war figures.
But most of our people
are just the, you know,
folks who have lived
in your neighborhood.
So I take a look at this.
And sometimes it's obvious,
obvious enough that I'm dealing
with the same person;
sometimes it's not.
This is where I might pull
in my contributors and say,
"You just might want to
take a look at these."
They don't always know
either, but we're trying
to index one person one
way as much as we can.
Corporate names; postcard publishers
have been the bane of my existence
since we've started
harvesting to DPLA.
There was just absolutely
no control.
And people just key in
what they see on the back.
And a fair amount of them
are in authority files,
so I do try to normalize those.
Oh, God. And then,
again, we have a lot
of our local businesses,
and clubs, and things.
So again, here's where
I take a look.
And the bottom example,
I'm not exactly sure
that that's the same story.
I could have changed
names over time.
So again, I might throw that
back to my contributors.
I do try not to get into a
lot of intellectual work here,
but I do take a look at
subjects for smaller collections
when things really jump out at me.
Like we do allow multiple
vocabularies.
And sometimes they'll use the
same term from two different ones.
And I know that the DPLA will
kind of rather not have that.
I think you're dealing with that
at some level, and may be able
to pull them out I heard,
but -- or reduce redundancy.
But I try to do that first.
I do catch typos.
Crazy unauthorized heading,
I don't know why they
thought this was a Library
of Congress subject
heading, but they did.
So I kind of do that when the
collection's small enough.
Sometimes we have some
over indexers, you know,
that they treat image indexing
like a game of "I Spy", you know.
[Laughter] So I might do something
there, or sometimes not enough.
So I might throw a couple in.
And I've talked to them
first before I do this.
They're okay with me doing it.
And they love me, and
they trust me [inaudible].
All right.
So I don't have a slide on original
formats, because it's a disaster.
That is one area where
we just had no control.
Again, we had a big meeting,
we all sat around the table,
and try to get museum people, and
archive people, and library people
to agree on even what
the word means.
So what, you know, "Jen,
what's the format of a chair?
How about a dress?"
I'm like, "I don't know.
Do what works for you,
and be consistent."
They're not consistent at all.
And that is, again, where I've
cleaned things up as much as I can.
We also stick kind of
form genre information
in the same field with
extent information.
And punctuation is
all over the place.
So I'm doing my best
because ESDN wants
to parse those two
pieces of information out.
So that -- we're going to
have to go back and clean some
of that up moving forward.
[ Silence ]
Okay. This one isn't
supposed to be in there.
But yes, we have to update some
of our metadata guidelines
and the right statement.
I didn't mention rights,
because right now I just make
sure that everybody has one.
One thing I want to let you
all know if you're thinking
about starting a hub, you don't
have to go through this level
of cleanup that I go through.
All the DPLA requires of you is
a title and a right statement,
and make sure things are
mount [phonetic] correctly.
But we want our stuff to
be as clean as possible.
So now's the time.
You know, am I going to go
back and do all this, no.
Now's the time where
I'm looking at it.
And we are going to be
doing big rights work.
Our right statements
need a lot of help.
And I've started to do
something seed planting.
I've been following the DPLA since
they started getting the right
on rights [phonetic] project
and then through the white paper
that was released in the fall.
And I kind of let my people know,
"This is coming, and now it's here."
So we'll all be ready.
And I've been asked to come talk to
boards and directors, and things,
which makes me really nervous.
So I'm not sure about that.
Oh, and my slide about the
-- this is the old version.
So it's okay.
It's fine.
So let me just mention what happens
with our non-hosted repositories
when ESDN works with them.
So there's lots of
different systems in play.
Sometimes the sharing
isn't even there.
So there's no OIA feed.
So that has to be developed
or configured first.
And then Chris said
-- a lot of times --
you know, these better funded and
better staffed organizations tend
to have professionals
doing the metadata.
So things tend to be pretty clean,
but they can be very
domain-specific;
so art, and music, and things.
So sometimes getting the
mapping right is challenging.
As has been mentioned, you
know, you kind of lose some
of your really specific field
labels when you go to DPLA,
so kind of working
through those issues.
And I -- yes so -- yes
there's my mapping.
Ad then Chris does all his
crazy transformations, and John,
and it's all beautiful, and
awesome, and we love it.
And I just have to say that
we have checked our stats,
up 30% since we started
contributing to DPLA.
So Q&A time.
[ Silence ]
[ Applause ]
>> Kerri Willette: And that's
why we have stuff in DPLA.
So I -- we kind of thought this
would be set up like a table
for like, questions and answers.
But would you guys
mind coming up here?
I know you hate me.
Please come up.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes; right this way.
Yes; just cuddle in behind here.
So I'd like to give
everybody the opportunity --
I mean, I have some like
seed questions I can ask
in case nobody has any, but I
think it would be more interesting
if you all ask the questions you're
interested in hearing more about,
and one of us can answer.
Do you want to start over here?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
I talk to them.
And part of the reason
why now is the time is
because those are challenging
conversations to have.
But most people have been
pretty receptive to it.
So we just -- I just do it.
And I don't do an awful lot of that.
Some collections are better
in that area than others.
So I just have -- I'm very nice.
[Laughter] And I'm a good
cheerleader, you know?
And I always start with
all of the positives.
And then, I'm like, "You
know, there might be --
" and I don't get into
specific records.
It's like, "I've kind of noticed a
little of this," and they're like,
"Fine, go ahead, do it," so.
>> Susan D'Entremont: And
I just wanted to jump in,
because like we said we each treat
our regions a little differently.
In our region for most -- except
for the very smallest places we
actually tell them what's wrong,
and have the institutions do
the cleanup, because that way
when they go and add more --
>> Laura Osterhout:
They'll do it right.
[Laughs]
>> Susan D'Entremont: They're
more likely to do it right.
>> Laura Osterhout: Right.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: Right.
>> Susan D'Entremont: So.
>> Kerri Willette: And that works
really well for us at the hub,
because the more cleanup that
happens at the local level,
the less we need to intervene
and maintain those
interventions over time.
So for us in New York, that's
really been at the high level.
Our goal is not to do a lot of like,
"We're going to make
it all perfect," or,
"We're going to change
it all to this thing."
We're like pretty baseline, "It's
going to go through to the DPLA
if it has these, you know, a
thumbnail and these things."
But at the local level these
guys are doing all that work
with the institutions directly.
>> Susan D'Entremont: But they
will tell -- I mean ESDN --
>> Kerri Willette: Yes, we do.
>> Susan D'Entremont:
Definitely gives us great feedback
about what they like
to see cleaned up.
>> Kerri Willette: Yes.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: Yes;
and as they move forward --
like some of it is just follow
the guidelines, dates correctly.
>> Susan D'Entremont: Most of it.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
So some of it's that.
And then I've cleaned up
all of their vocabularies.
And I do have to work with them on
some of the more nuanced issues.
So yes; we have a conversation
and then I am moving forward
they're getting it better.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: Yes, yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
Oh dear, I'm sorry.
>> Susan D'Entremont: No, no;
they're great guidelines, Jen.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: But
mine haven't been updated yet,
[inaudible].
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Kerri Willette: I don't --
you know, to -- everybody --
you know, people have their
love-hate thing with CONTENTdm.
But frankly, it's worked really
well for us as an aggregator, right?
Like John Menyo [phonetic], who's
over here, he's our programmer
who actually has to write
the code that gets --
>> Laura Osterhout: [Inaudible].
We've never me him.
[Laughter]
>> Kerri Willette: He's
like our Snuffleupagus.
People in this state they
don't believe he exists.
He's over here.
He had a pocketknife and they
wouldn't let him in this morning.
>> Susan D'Entremont: He gets
the red things [inaudible].
>> Kerri Willette:
That's another story.
But yes, we -- stuff from
CONTENTdm, I think as Jen said,
if things are weird but
they're consistently weird,
we can deal with that.
And CONTENTdm has some
consistently weird things about it.
And we don't care.
It comes to us and we
-- because I don't have
to do any of it, John fixes it.
And then, you know, like it
can be pretty varied in terms
of the descriptive
data that's in there.
And we kind of let that pass
for the most part when we can --
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: Yes, right.
>> Kerri Willette: And we can lots
of different channels
of consistent, right?
So everybody doesn't have to
be consistent to one another.
You know, this stream of
data can be consistent
to itself, and that works.
And then this other stream can be
completely different from that,
but consistent to itself.
And that works for us as the
aggregator, if that make sense.
Right; except for the date,
which we won't get into.
>> Laura Osterhout: The date.
[Laughter]
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> Susan D'Entremont:
I don't anticipate people
being eagerly receptive,
but I'm very hopeful that the
ESDN staff will give us training
and language to help with that.
No. I think you've alluded to
the fact that people have --
they feel very personal about
what they think people should do
with their stuff and
their statements.
>> Laura Osterhout: I think
people will welcome some kind
of clarification, though.
>> Susan D'Entremont: Yes.
>> Kerri Willette: Yes, yes.
>> Laura Osterhout: Because
they're really, you know,
they don't know what to
do about right statements.
And if we can come to them with
these 11, you know, statements,
and we can say, "This
is what they mean."
Maybe consult with them,
"This probably applies
to what you're doing, and you
can feel comfortable using it,"
I think that's huge, you know?
>> Susan D'Entremont: Yes, yes.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: It's
time to free the public domain.
And I think that's been a challenge
for a lot of organizations.
[Laughter].
And so it's a cultural shift that
I've seen happening over 15 years,
but we started 15 years ago,
and a lot of our right
statements are very restrictive.
>> Laura Osterhout: Yes.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
First of all,
don't have any rights information.
They just say, "You can't use that."
>> Kerri Willette: Don't.
>> Laura Osterhout: Right, right.
>> Kerri Willette: Yes.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
And they don't say why.
And then a lot of the
times, they can't.
So it's just -- it's the
reality of the situation.
The DPLA gives us a lot of cover.
Thank you so much for doing this --
>> Laura Osterhout: Yes, huge.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
Because now we can just point
up right up the ladder.
Like this is it.
And, you know --
>> Laura Osterhout: What they said.
[Laughs]
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: Let
just move forward with this.
But -- and the people I
work with have come along.
It's the people above
them [inaudible].
>> Susan D'Entremont: Yes, true.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
[Inaudible].
So I want to have like the panels.
I want to take like a statewide
road show, and like bring in people
who are not just me to talk to.
>> Laura Osterhout: Let's do this.
Yes.
>> Kerri Willette: Yes, yes.
And we -- one of the lovely
things about a distributed hub is
that we have expertise all over
the state that we can draw from,
and that want to contribute
to these efforts.
So we're going to be
able to all sit down --
you know, like we'll have a
subcommittee that comes together
in a room, that's basically
all of us sitting here,
and Carly's unit this
year from METRO too,
and she'll run that group for us.
[Laughter] And then, you know,
like we'll be able to say like,
"This is how we're going
to do this across the state
to help people figure out
what they should do next,
and what we need from them.
And then we'll also share that
out, of course, to all of you.
But we're excited.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Kerri Willette: That's
a great question, Liz.
And so basically the deal
is everybody in the regions,
they're working directly with
institutions on their collections
that are often in a, you know,
hosted CONTENTdm, or Islandora,
in the case of METRO, repository.
So those are really the
collection managers,
and they're also the people
who are doing digitization
trainings and all that stuff.
But Chris, at the hub level,
is taking their OIA feeds.
Right; so when Jen does
her amazing metadata
in their CONTENTdm instance,
she's working with Chris, then,
to map that one collection
stream or that --
many collections, but one
data stream to our data model.
And he's meanwhile working with
Susan, and working with Laura,
and working with Ann, to pull
in data streams from each
of those other collections.
So he's actually normalizing across
all of these different institutions,
and then also working with our state
library, and our state archives,
and our, you know, many other
institutions that host locally.
He works directly with them
so that we can get those
data streams normalized.
So we pass one single
stream to DPLA.
I've passed it straight to
Gretchen in the backup, I'm sorry.
They passed it right there, so.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: We do.
We've talked about this last night.
>> Kerri Willette: Oh.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Laura Osterhout: Ah, yes.
>> Susan D'Entremont: Good question.
>> Kerri Willette: That
is a good question.
>> Laura Osterhout: Do you want
to talk about ESDN [inaudible]?
>> Kerri Willette: You
talk about the state first.
>> Laura Osterhout: Okay.
The nine library councils
are actually directly funded
by New York State.
We receive sort of like
general operating funding.
We're actually considered
library systems in the state.
And there's some wacky metric way
they decide who gets the funding.
I mean, you know, METRO
gets a lot more
because they have a lot more
people than we do upstate.
But then we also get some
additional revenue from statewide --
different grants to run
different types of programs.
We used to get -- was it
LSDA that was federal money?
We don't get that anymore.
But then ESDN is funded sort
of a little differently.
>> Kerri Willette: So ESDN
-- like three years ago,
all of the councils came together,
they said we want to
become a DPLA hub.
You know, the big strategic planning
meetings happened, blah, blah, blah.
Next thing you know
-- this is my version.
I like -- [makes sounds]
I wasn't there.
So this is what I've been told, when
I was just a twinkle in their eye.
Basically, METRO's board --
because each of the councils
has its own board of directors
or whatever they're
called, "Board of Trustees".
>> Laura Osterhout:
Yes, trustees, yes.
>> Kerri Willette: And so
basically METRO's board said, "Yes;
we want to kick this off."
But really we didn't have
at any of the councils,
a way to handle the technology
and the project management
and everything on top of whatever
everyone was already doing.
And you may be familiar
with that situation.
And so the Empire State Library
Network kicked in some money
and then, METRO board
basically funded the rest.
So it's three fulltime positions.
And we're very fortunate.
And it was funded for three years.
It was funded for one year
initially, and then three years.
So we're hitting the third year now.
And we're having a
lot of conversations
about how funny it will
work going forward.
And that's what my
next year will be.
[Laughs] So I'll have more answers.
>> Susan D'Entremont: And then also
we do charge member fees to our --
the councils charge
member fees to our members.
And that's been another
difficult conversation,
because there are definitely
people that hold material
that probably they want in
DPLA, or we should have in DPLA
that are not our traditional library
museum archives type members.
And how do we deal with that?
And we don't have any
great answers yet.
We're talking about that
in the next year as well.
>> Kerri Willette: Yes.
[ Silence ]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
We -- well, I mean, it
depends on what it is, right?
I mean, we don't do a ton
of intervention at ESDN,
because we're getting it from too
many sources and it would be a lot
of -- you know, it's all --
we use REPOX, which is
an XXLT-based system.
So it would be a lot of
writing individual scripts
to clean things up.
So we do pass many
inconsistencies onto DPLA.
And I will say this, we
pass that information back
down the chain along
to the institutions
and ask them to address it.
So we're not -- there are
cases where we'll fix things
that we just have to fix,
but we're really pushing
down like along the sort of chain of
contribution to try and get it fixed
at the source, because I think
that's better for everyone.
But then also we can't
do it otherwise.
>> Laura Osterhout: And it can't
be perfect, and it never will be.
>> Kerri Willette: Right.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: Yes.
>> Laura Osterhout: But it's
better to have it in there,
you know, and everybody agrees.
>> Kerri Willette: Yes.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: And
in the a wide-world metadata,
like go look for World War II
posters they're been digitized over
and over again, and look at all of
the records for the same poster,
and you'll see lots of
different [overlapping].
>> Laura Osterhout: Yes, yes.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero: So that --
I mean, it's just metadata
is messy anyway.
So we do the best we can
within our little [inaudible].
>> Kerri Willette: Yes.
And there are often inconsistencies
that are correct [laughter]
between types of contributing
institutions too,
like what may be correct in
the museum world may be --
>> Laura Osterhout: Sure.
Yes.
>> Kerri Willette: Very
different in the archives world,
may be very different
in the public library.
So we want people to have local
to say, and to make those choices
for their collections,
because they're the experts
in their context and collections.
So we're going to take what they
give us; and we want to, so.
>> Jennifer Palmentiero:
So don't be afraid.
>> Kerri Willette:
Yes, don't be afraid.
[Laughter] Don't be afraid.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
I think we're out of time, too.
So thank all of you.
[Applause] Let us know -- if you
ever have questions, let me know.
Contact us.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.